all right so we have the the embryonic
uh training that's already now this is
no longer a cut this is just a line and
then I practice he makes connection and
then I go okay let's move past
that this is not a block that would
violate IO principles you
see so I can't do the same timing of the
embryonic version okay I don't have to
kill my UK but it is more challenging to
all right because it's not hey get ready
get ready to receive you see that it's
in the motion okay so as I
[Music]
go
when you're working this note that I
don't look at his
weapon keep your eyes in the fight okay
so
boom you're killing his weapon you
you're killing his cut so you're not
letting this cut get and attacking it on
his power AR before it even gets in you
you'll have shut it
down okay let's try it so uh some of
you some of you uh that you don't count
that as a block you see like you're
going to do the technique do the
technique you see that you don't you
don't count that as a block you
understand it's like oh it's barely you
see that when I go
do you
understand why is that happening because
it's y y do you understand do you get
that okay so you had your weapon put
your weapon out on the
Block you
see this thing is going to it's not
going to let you do what you think
you're going to do so it's going to go
here and it's starting what did you want
to do you wanted to drop the the uh the
hands you see and you wanted your tip to
raise but pressure is going pressure is
going there do you see so as it all
lowers it's it's a matter of fractions
of a second and fractions of an inch but
as this is going down that thing is
going less and less and less into the
atos very similar to the embryonic when
you're bringing it down my sword and
then you turn your grip remember as
opposed to rotating the cross and then
comes down you remember that okay so
same thing's happening it looks
like it looks like it's going to be fine
CU you barely do it do it how you were
doing come on dude you see come on it
looks like it's going to be fine but why
it happens cuz UK weits here
you see and UK is not supposed to wait
there UK is supposed to come around do
their KY gut and finish the
cut you got it but in your training
culture you go
here and then he gets to do what could
not happen in reality okay so you don't
have to go fast if you don't want to but
you have to go
smooth you see
it's not my job to make connection with
him it's his job to make connection with
me some of you don't want to get hurt
right and that's why you go hey I'll
make a silent deal with you I'll make
connection for you you and then you do
your block I'll ignore that you block
and then I'll take your CH but I'm
telling you if you'd rather not get
hurt at all the best
thing is to just shut them
down I didn't even have to take the k
okay
all right let's
go oh pay attention to where I'm
actually making contact with his sword
okay uh forget about when let's just
where all
right I go home not not not there not
there not on the 6:00 of his sword so
12:00 at the m
and then here at The Cutting Edge will
say six that's not where I'm doing it
okay so there's no
reason to stay there boom not going to
have that Cut's going to keep going and
you're not going to get the push okay
does my Joe pass through 6:00 yes it
does pay pay attention as my Joe moves
you see it goes under
6:00 but it doesn't wait wait to make
contact at 6:00 so just on mind movement
one
two and then around so all that's the
same if you just watch my joke one two
and around all that is the same only
when is what's going on but I don't want
you to pay attention to when yet I want
you to see where okay so we go
and again the
cut
where
where where on his
booking we'll do it
again
one we'll do it
where someone put your sword out someone
come touch it
no not even close let's test it here
okay we're going to watch go back and
watch go back and
watch want to try it
again
yeah got it cuz I'm attacking his hands
hit
subba I'm not I'm not fighting his
weapon I'm fighting his cut ability do
you understand so it's over here on the
side is
where we go and you see my movement is
exactly the same but now when it's much
earlier don't start doing
this you didn't do the
movement but don't start waving
here you got to do the movement and hit
that
part okay let's go